As we start to wrap up this course, I wanted to give you an overview of the animation blueprint
functionality and also a quick pro tip as well for anyone using vehicles inside of Unreal.
So a really good pro tip is the rotation of tires, which we see requested quite a lot.
So we're not going to dig into how to create this example, but I just wanted to provide
an example tire rotation control rig setup because this will likely be very useful in
your project.
You can dig apart, pick apart the different nodes and kind of recreate this setup.
But I just wanted to provide an example image in case that was useful to you.
And then when we're talking about the animation blueprint overview, we essentially have the
two different graphs.
So we have the event graph for logic.
The event graph will house a lot of the blueprint control and any kind of specific input content.
And then also the animation graph will be for the control and the flow of information.
So you may end up with kind of state machine functionality for the flow of information
there.
When we talk about the event graph, it's essentially a very similar to a blueprint event graph.
You have variables in here.
So you may have the car movement speed variable, for example.
So the event graph will control variables and logic.
You know, if you're wanting to drive this vehicle around, you'd have a lot of the logic
there in the event graph.
So then we actually get this information and we send it through to the animation graph.
And so if you want any additional resources on the specific functionalities, it's definitely
worth checking out the documentation page on that for some additional resources there.